president Trump greeted college football
fans in Atlanta before last night's
Alabama Georgia title game his
appearance on the field for the national
anthem followed weeks of the president
criticizing the NFL for allowing pregame
protests earlier in Nashville he touted
his recent tax reform victory market
Brennan is at the White House Margaret
gird good morning and Wow look at the
fog out there where are the werewolf's
exactly well good morning to you Nora
and the president certainly would like
to clear the air here in Washington he
spent yesterday deep in Trump country
and in Tennessee he gave his first
policy speech in more than three weeks
he's trying to put to rest some of those
damaging comments made by officials in a
recent book about him whether it was
singing the national anthem at the
college football championship game in
Georgia I like you too I like you to
Tennessee or basking in the warmth of an
adoring crowd of Tennessee farmers hours
earlier oh are you happy you voted for
me you are so lucky that I gave you that
riblets president Trump enjoyed a brief
respite from the continuing firestorm
over Michael Wolf's fire in fury the
intensely critical book on the Trump
White House has soured relations between
the president and his former chief
strategist Steve Manon in the book
already a best-seller Bannon called
Donald Trump Jr's 2016 meeting with
Russians treasonous said if vodka Trump
was dumb as a brick and accused her
husband Jared Kushner of financial
crimes White House spokesman Hogan
Gidley told reporters on Air Force One
that the attacks on the first family
were repugnant and grotesque
I just don't think Trump attorney
Charles harder had tried to force fire
in fury publisher Henry Holt to stop the
release of the book last week yesterday
the CEO of Macmillan Holt's parent
company released a memo to staff calling
the move flagrantly unconstitutional
this is an underlying principle of our
democracy we cannot stand silent the
people in the White House are like
everybody else in the country what's
going to happen here author Michael
Wolfe told
CBS this morning that some members of
president Trump's inner circle are so
concerned about the president's mental
acuity that they question whether to
take extraordinary measures to remove
him from office a claim that White House
officials flatly deny now here at the
White House President Trump will host a
bipartisan group of senators today to
discuss immigration reform and it's
going to be an uphill battle he is
asking for any kind of immigration deal
to include funding for that border wall
with Mexico and Gayle the price tag
right now is 18 billion dollars Wow
Thank You Margaret well Nora's right it
does look like a movie set no war works
but there's somebody with a yellow vest
walking behind you thank you very much
Margaret
he looks safe he let's say thank you
very much